Debugging statements left in the code may even come up with a security problem.
In Mac OS versions 10.7.2/10.7.3, there was a security issue because a programmer
had left debugging print statements in the code.
This would result in the following situation--you as a user would enter your password into the Mac
the Mac would then let you in or not let you in but at the same time would store your password
in the clear in, a log that would be visible for anyone--
anyone with access to the machine of course, and this again would require a password.
On a multi-user machine, for instance, or somebody having physical access to a hard drive,
a mean checker could not go and retrieve your password in the clear,
and that's simply because of some left debugging statement in there.